janet yellen let me read that story on
page nine what she says she wants to do
dems plan
billionaires unrealized gains tax to
help fund the two trillion dollar
spending bill a new york post story
president biden's two trillion dollar
spending package continues to stall as
senior democrats are hoping to finalize
a proposal on a new annual tax on
billionaires unrealized capital gains
let me read that one more time hoping to
finalize a proposal on a new annual tax
on billionaires
unrealized capital gains do you know
what that means
they made money on an investment they
haven't taken the money out the equities
on that house the equities in the
company the equities in the stock they
haven't taken the money out janet yellen
and biden want to tax unrealized gains
that hasn't been taken out by the
individual which is absolutely ludicrous
i mean if if somebody said this stuff 20
years ago they always said you've lost
your mind but it's becoming a reality
today
we probably will have a wealth tax says
nancy pelosi come from sunday the
proposal which is being reviewed by
senate finance committee chairman ron
wyden uh a democrat from oregon would
impose an annual tax on unrealized
capital gains on liquid assets held by
billionaires treasury secretary janet
yellen said the proposal will likely
only affect less than a thousand of the
nation's wealthiest citizen i don't care
if it's a thousand if it's 500 10 000
leave them alone they keep creating jobs
i don't care what their net worth is let
them keep creating jobs and have an
incentive to create jobs because if they
don't do what they do
you're going to take a hit and by the
way
again it goes back down to why a
thousand why are they the richest of the
riches how about the person that's worth
40 million how rich is 40 million to a
person making 15 bucks an hour very rare
how rich is 10 million to someone that's
making 50
how rich is a million dollars to a
person that's making 50 how rich is a
half a million dollars cash in savings
to a person that's making 15 bucks an
hour so what's rich
rich is only any taxes that you will not
pay so if nancy pelosi is worth 300
million
let's make sure we pet the taxes a
billion so i don't have to pay in any of
it it's always i don't want to
experience the pain
you covered this a couple of podcasts
yeah this was like a month ago it's
always the person who's just a little
bit richer than you that's where you
want to start yeah
and the problem is it's slippery slope
you know what this reminds me of because
you'll appreciate this i think
there was a lot because obviously you're
in the life insurance world there was a
long there was talks about
because obviously a life insurance the
death benefit is is tax-free oh yeah but
but at one point they were proposing
uh taxing the cash value buildup within
the policy
do you remember this of course i do but
that didn't pass it was rule 7702 that
they wanted to eliminate to tax the cash
value and the second value or the pul or
an iul or that stuff yeah and it didn't
pass that it didn't pass yeah and you
know who was leading that elizabeth
warren
was that d.o.l was that all that was
that
but by the way the camp that's in right
now is the cam that could do that yeah
that's the camp that's in right now well
to to
our last friend was it josh i know
whoever he said well why don't we just
let him have what they want listen
that's the whole point of america is to
have
the debate to have the ideas and find
out which ideas are actually right you
like
gerard likes to say that democrats are
the gas and republicans are the breaks
and there's two sides of the eagle
wherever you want to look at it but
that's the whole point of all right this
is the idea i want to go with hell no
we're not doing the idea and then at
some point there needs to be a
compromise and that's the problem in
america right now is that everyone's
entrenched on their sides
let's coalesce in the middle by the way
the bitcoin community is uh
uh uh thinking that if hyperinflation
happens bitcoin's gonna go to a hundred
thousand five hundred thousand a million
dollars that's what that's why jack
dorsey is probably saying very big
encrypted do you really think he needs
another billion dollars no but he's not
he's all right
cash app square and he's very big like
one guy you know another conference do
you think he was the guest speaker now
here's the other part you know peter is
a peter shift the gold guy yeah she's
thinking that gold's going to take off
with this and gold's going to go to a
whole different level look the idea is
the following this is going to happen
own
non-duplicatable assets keyword own
non-duplicate
assets very simple nft's
non-duplicatable assets to that
community is it is as non-duplicatable
as it can be let me answer your question
by the way you said do you think he
cares about another billion dollars jack
dorsey
do you think he's a little bit
competitive
dorsey
so when you look around and he sees the
zucks worth a hundred billion but even
elon musk worth 200 something billion
the bezos 150 billion and he's worth
what is he worth i don't know i'm
guessing 10 billion
i don't know
who he is one 14. 14.
you don't think he's a little
competitive saying i got to get to 100
some point but even even in that case i
think so he's not going to be the only
one i think you guys
i'm not saying he's not going by the way
i love what rudolph ramirez just said
you can vote your way into socialism but
you cannot vote your way out what a
powerful thing to say you can vote your
way into socialism you cannot vote your
way out uh rodolfo that is extremely
powerful quote you just posted right now
but yeah i don't think that's what he's
driven by i just tell you it's this is
let me talk to the investor let's talk
to the investor the person that's
listening to this right now
is this a probably a good time to own a
little bit of gold
maybe is this a good time to own a
little bit of crypto you know maybe get
a little bit of ethereum get a little
bit of whatever you know you
maybe
is it is it time to consider getting a
little bit of collectible cards or comic
books that are limited edition yeah
maybe this is not a bad time to
set aside some of those things that are
again
non-duplicatable assets if you do that
and hyperinflation happens it actually
favors you if you do that i have two
things on board which is interesting uh
first one obviously when they look at
people and you look at elon musk 280
billion dollars it's not like he's
sitting on a
on a pile of cash at 280 billion dollars
it's all invested in his company it's
all going to be taxed once he takes it
out once he takes payment and if the
tesla stock crashes so is his net worth
so it's not like he's sitting on it and
he's just kind of walking around with a
checking account with 280 billion so
it's a completely different way of how
that would then function of just doing
this and then the other part of it is if
it's just the thousand wealthiest
if they get it passed and approved
why not do 2000 why not do the top ten
percent like it it'll just
catastrophically it'll just snowball
from catastrophic how many times do they
not promise if you're making less than
this your taxes aren't going to be
changed and then two weeks later
something comes out well maybe six
hundred dollars of taxes and that's
gonna change it
exactly because people are like this is
pathetic if you're going to come after
my 600 of taxes so they're going to
they're going to find a way to just get
it in the bank
we got to deal with all this crap now
so they then they just say or we'll meet
you back at the 10 000 number yeah it's
uh maybe not we're good where we're at
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you